now let me finally turn to one
particular system that's been of great
interest to us molecular motors are of
course the scene a quinone example of
how the jiggling z' and wiggling z' are
put to work to do something that nature
wants and needs and the we've studied
several different motors but I will talk
just about one of them because of course
the physiology and medicine prize was
given about the function of vesicles
which provide nutrients and other
materials which are necessary for the
function of a cell the one point that
hasn't been wasn't stressed in the in
these lectures not all the vesicles need
to be moved from one place to another
but kinesin which was discovered in 1985
is very important in the sense that it's
a molecule that does in fact do the
transport of vesicles the vesicles are
up here we know almost nothing about
their structure how they are attached
but it's a molecule what's actually two
molecules that have each one of each one
has this globular foot as you will see
and then they're tied together by strand
to form a coiled coil which holds the
vesicle and what the physiology and
medicine lectures were mainly about this
how the vesicles open enclosed to give
to give up their cargo at just the right
time this is concerned with how they
move around and again this is a cartoon
and we'll just watch it the microtubules
down below and that
two globular feet and here's a real time
motive photograph enlarged about a
hundred times under thousand times white
where they kinesin molecules are
actually moving on the microtubule but I
now want to focus more specifically on
how kinesin functions and if you look
carefully at this you can see that
kinesin walks in the sense that we walk
it puts the left foot forward and then
it puts the right foot forward and then
the left foot forward
now
so that it is walking in one sense but
of course it's not surprising that um
this these two molecules tied together
don't walk really very well and to me
what the way they're walking is much
more like a person who has artificial
legs who sort of walks forward like this
but that a molecule molecule ER system
without all the things we have to make
our feet work and do this is amazing to
me